you want to be a doctor you thought
about being a doctor at one point which
I find very hard to believe you're such
a natural performer yeah but you know it
was just because I was a fan of medical
shows on TV it wasn't I didn't care
about science
he didn't care and you didn't care as a
guy yeah show Quincy and I used to think
wow that could be me Medical Center yeah
but and then so now I was in pre-med and
I would have to you know do rounds and
stuff like that but I was so far behind
that I once had to sneak into McMahan
McMaster University where they kept
frozen cats because in the dissection
class and I went in and I stole a cat
and and and cuz you were behind you were
supposed to have I was very behind and I
hadn't been to classes because I've been
you know doing the shows and so I took
the cat home I love your summary of your
career in show business
yeah there are serious students yeah
yeah yeah you know cure the ills of the
world so I had to steal the cat the
frozen cat bring it home but meanwhile I
had a 17 year old cat so I'm up in the
staying all night dissecting my cat from
aldehyde everywhere and my poor cat big
fattest cat you'd ever seen in your life
right the worms in her stool had type 2
diabetes
[Applause]
poor Tiger coming in and just running
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
you